I just want to start off if I may with
claims in the Sun newspaper that a BBC
presenter is paid a 17 year old now 20
year old 35 000 pounds for explicit
pictures do you have any concerns by the
way this has been handled by the BBC
well these are very very serious
allegations and the BBC have said that
they have processes in place but I think
as public attention and concern grows
the BBC is going to have to act very
swiftly to deal with these allegations
and to set out what they are doing to
investigate them I mean according to the
alleged victim's mother
she complained to the BBC on May the
19th but the presenter then stayed on
air until quite recently I mean that
could be as many six weeks later yes as
I say I we will have to see what the BBC
has to say about this but these are very
serious allegations and I can quite
understand the public concern about them
pretty Patel former home secretary has
said the treatment of the complaint was
derisory and she said that the BBC
should hold a full and transparent
investigation do you agree with that
well it may well be that that happens in
due course I mean with allegations of
this kind as we as a government have
worked very hard over the years to try
to help complainants of very serious
allegations uh both in the criminal
courts and with the police and I would
expect other institutions that have
responsibilities to the public to have
similar high standards you know you've
done quite a lot on this yourself
haven't you
um is there an issue with the way that
we treat victims in this country who
come forward with allegations well we do
everything we can to support victims and
obviously I'm not commenting on these
specific allegations but more generally
we have tried we've conducted a forensic
examination of every stage of the
criminal justice process to try to
support complaints giving their best
evidence so for example we've rolled out
video recorded evidence across the
country to help complainants give their
evidence as quickly as they possibly can
because we know that sometimes that can
be a pressure and it can lead to them
stopping the case if they're concerned
about delays but I would always
encourage victims of such Behavior to
come forward
just to go back to the specifics of this
allegation
what we've seen in recent days is other
high-profile BBC presenters having to
come out on social media to say it
wasn't then in the case of some people
they've even had to go to the police to
report people who wrongly accuse them on
social media
how concerning is theirs
well I think in this age now that we
have social media we are go we are
having to find ways of managing what
that can mean you know the social media
can be a great thing but it can also
lead to some very
um significant concerns uh in cases
where perhaps there's an investigational
going or uh people are making
allegations unfounded allegations and so
there is a responsibility for social
media companies to take care of what is
on their uh their sites and this is why
with the Online safety Bill we are
really tightening up the laws so that we
have that assurance that we all want
when it comes to the internet not just
in relation to these sorts of
allegations but mums and dads worrying
about their children's access to the
internet and so on we want to try and
make the internet as safe as it possibly
can be is there a argument that the
presenter should be named
as I said I'm going to if you'll forgive
me I'm just going to stay away from this
because I think the BBC have to explain
what they have done in recent weeks and
these allegations are so serious that at
this stage I I won't be commenting
further okay that makes sense
um thank you for what you have said
about and what you feel about oval to
say about the uh case and the
allegations
um I want to talk to you a little bit
about international news now uh
President Biden the U.S president
shortly in town the PM's going to meet
him before they go to Nato
now of course the US has recently agreed
to supply Costa bombs to Ukraine is that
something that you agree with well we're
very pleased that President Biden is
coming this week it's going to be the
fifth time that uh the Prime Minister
and the president have met in the last
five months and so the relationship is
the special relationship is still very
much strong and secure in relation to
cluster bombs we the UK have signed the
convention that prohibits their use and
discourages their use and of course we
stick by that convention and we are
trying to do what we can to support
Ukraine so last year we spent some 2.3
billion pounds in giving Ukraine help in
all sorts of practical ways including
heavy artillery and tanks and so on and
we will continue that this year
um but we we have signed this convention
and for us that is our position on these
bombs is it something that Russia Cena
will be raising with President Biden
well I imagine of course the subject of
Ukraine will be discussed not least
because we have the NATO meeting this
week but um the president and the Prime
Minister have a very very good working
relationship
um okay right let's talk a little bit
about the economy shall we because of
course as Financial Secretary of the
Treasury you are responsible for the tax
system in the UK how happy are you with
the current levels of Taxation
well I'm a conservative so of course I
want our taxes to be as low as possible
but I also believe in fiscal
responsibility and so coming out of the
of the pandemic when we spent 400
billion pounds supporting people through
furlough through more funding for the
NHS through various schemes that we put
in place rightly and people were very
very you know they wanted us to do this
during the pandemic we responded quickly
we responded really robustly we have to
now pay back that money and and act
responsibly with those debts of course
we have since then had Ukraine and we
have again spent 94 billion pounds to
help people with the cost of living
pressures that we're all facing over
recent months that's 94 billion pounds
that we have to account okay I want to
go back to some of the things that so
this is why we're having to look at
raising for example corporation tax I
want to go back to some of the things
you're talking about there on covid and
also Ukraine in a moment but just to
kind of be crystal clear about tax
burden so I think we can have a little
look at what it is the overall tax
burden in the UK at levels frankly you
haven't seen for decades well this
feature may hunt effectively ruled out
big tax cuts ahead of a general election
in an interview with the financial times
we won't countens tax cuts if they make
the battle against inflation harder
and yet look at the current tax burden
is that really the right policy well we
have to be fiscally responsible so I do
not want us to be passing on our debt to
our children and our grandchildren which
is why we've said we have to have sound
money we cannot be borrowing uh money as
perhaps labor would like to 28 billion
pounds
you can't really criticize labor Labor's
economic plan when you look at the state
of the economy after 13 years of the
conservatives well actually in terms of
the number one Enemy at the moment is
inflation and one of the reasons leading
to inflation one of the factors behind
the stickiness of inflation is that we
have a very tight labor market which is
a good news because that means after 13
years of conservative government we have
more people at work than ever very very
high employment rates but that is having
an impact on inflation and so that is
why it's spring budget you saw the
chancellor announced a huge package of
support to get people back into the
workforce including the transformational
Child Care Program that is going to help
mums and dads back into the workforce
who perhaps are finding child care to
are too expensive at the moment you're
talking about sound money under the
conservatives and I think we can have a
little look now at a global comparison
of the deficit and also debt levels and
you can see here how the UK is doing
this is a chart from the obr showing
there's 42 other countries around the
world we've got the third worst deficit
and when it comes to debt levels we've
got the fourth worst debt is this really
sound money under the conservatives and
this is precisely why we are having to
make very difficult decisions both the
Autumn statement and at Spring budget
but also why the prime minister's number
one focus is on tackling inflation
pay these back you know we are spending
120 billion pounds a year on debt
interest I would much rather we were
spending that money on the Public
Services we all care about but we have
to drive down this debt which we are
determined to do in the medium and long
term which is why it's one of the prime
minister's five priorities I guess my
question is help with those uh those
figures you know you're talking a moment
ago about covert and about the war in
Ukraine and how that's impacted the
economy in the UK well it's also
impacted all these other 42 economies as
well why are we doing so badly well if
you look if for example if you look at
in rates of inflation uh developed
economies around the world are facing
much higher inflation rates for all
sorts of reasons but we are particularly
exposed for example on gas prices we
have most of us are on the grid we're
very exposed to International gas prices
and so that is why last Autumn we
announced the energy price guarantee
which has not only helped halve
energy bills around the country it's
also knocked to percentage points off
inflation but we also want to help with
things such as food inflation we know
that we import 50 of our food my farmers
in Lincolnshire would wish that it was
far lower than that but because of that
we are much more susceptible to price
rises in the worldwide price of wheat
for example which means that then comes
through to our shelves on the
supermarkets and so as part of our work
to tackle all of this we're working with
supermarkets for example to make sure
that they're offering value ranges to
try to help people as you've described
who are finding times really tough at
the moment okay and there's obviously as
we've been talking about the economy big
question marks on whether or not the
prime minister is going to meet some of
his Pleasures when it comes to debt when
it comes to inflation
another of the Pledge is of course is to
stop the boats which is obviously not
really working we're seeing again large
numbers of people crossing at the
channel but the one thing you have
achieved on this is to actively make the
decision to paint over a children's
mural that was in a children's Asylum
Center and the idea was that it was too
welcoming you have a look at it here
mini Mickey Mouse Tom and Jerry there
and that was painted over the decision
taken by Robert generick the immigration
minister because it was too welcoming
well I think we've got to focus on the
fundamentals here if there are children
arriving in the United Kingdom via small
boats then as soon as they land in the
UK they are looked after properly you
know the local authorities step in they
have their welfare their health needs
and their schooling needs looked after
that is the fundamentals but we also
have to tackle we have to stop people
from uh working being enticed by
criminal gangs to cross the channel
because that journey in itself is such a
dangerous Journey it must be terrifying
for the for children who come across and
so that is why we're so focused on
stopping the boats and in fact if you
look at where we are this this year
today compared to where we were in a
year a year ago actually the number of
Crossings is down we have had a 90
percent
decrease in the number of crossings by
albanians because very very close
working with the Albanian authorities
and we are seeing the French deal that
we struck has led to 33 000 Crossings
being stopped so those are all steps in
the right direction but it is an
incredibly difficult uh problem and I
don't you know I don't think anyone
pretends that when the Prime Minister
set this priority he or anyone else was
saying it was going to be easy it is not
just look at this picture
I don't believe you're comfortable with
it
the decision to paint over I don't
believe it
well I I what I'm I'm not comfortable
with the idea that people would bring
children of course I can absolutely
understand that and but that's not the
decision of the children is it they end
up in the the decision
to paint over
this mural it's a place where kids go
they must be terrified when they again
sit on those chairs they're doing what's
happening they don't know where they're
going to go and there was an active
decision to paint over
Mickey and Minnie Mouse which is why the
fundamentals of how we care for those
children that's my question are you
comfortable with it I mean I I I've done
it would you when children come to the
UK in those very frightening
circumstances as we do we want them to
be looked after well
um and looked after properly by local
authorities that puts an enormous
pressure by the way on the local
authorities most affected by this you
know Kent is particularly at the
Forefront of this and we have got to
work we've got to find ways of being
fair to British citizens because the
more that people come across the more
pressures that puts on our Public
Services I mean the figures speak for
themselves four years ago by 300 people
came across in small boats last year it
was 45
000 people I think you can believe all
of that and still be
kind of uncomfortable about the idea
that you're part of the government that
would paint over this mural I I look I
what I care about is how those children
are looked after when they come here and
and I'm confident that they are given
the care and the welfare that we would
expect we would want okay
um just finally George Osborne uh got
married yesterday
um he had a slight hitch to his wedding
ceremony they didn't he he left the
church and a protester covered him in
Orange confetti now Justin Boyle have
have welcomed it they haven't exactly
taken responsibility
um but they have welcomed it's a lot of
speculation that they were behind it
what's your sort of reaction to this
you know this is a couple clearly in
early enough
on their wedding day and somebody has
apparently
um taken the opportunity to throw some
orange dust around I I find it
extraordinary with all of these sporting
events that we've seen this year you
know people have been looking forward to
Wimbledon or the ashes or whatever the
sporting event is some people have been
saving up a lot of money to you know pay
for their tickets or to they've gone to
the trouble of queuing at Wimbledon I
just I don't understand why an
organization would want to stop other
people from having fun and enjoyment and
they achieved nothing other than making
people feel upset when they're missing
out on the sporting event that they've
been looking forward to for a very long
time or indeed their own wedding okay
well strong words from both you and
Rachel Reeves on the subject this
morning thank you very much thank you